i don't know how difficult
it is to replicate that we were talking
offline about boston dynamics robots
they've recently been they did both
parkour
they did flips they've also done some
dancing
and something i think a lot about
because what most people
don't realize because they don't look
deep enough is
those robots are hard-coded to do those
things
the robots didn't figure it out by
themselves and yet
the the fundamental aspect of what it
means to be human
is that process of fearing out of making
mistakes
and then there's something about
overcoming those challenges and
mistakes and like figuring out how to
lose yourself in the magic of the
dancing
uh or just movement is what it means to
be human that learning process
so that's what i want to do with the
with the uh
almost as a fun side thing with the the
boston dynamics robots
is to have them learn and see what they
figure out
even if it even if they make mistakes i
want to let
spot make mistakes and in so doing
discover
what it means to be alive discover
beauty because i think that's the
essential aspect of mistakes
boston dynamics folks want spot to be
perfect
because they don't want spot to ever
make mistakes because it wants to
operate in the factories it wants to be
you know very safe and so on for me if
you construct the environment
if you construct a safe space for robots
and allow them to make mistakes
something beautiful might be discovered
but that requires a lot of brain power
so spot is currently very dumb and i'm
going to add
give it a brain so first make it c
currently can't see
meaning computer vision he has to
understand his environment has to see
all the humans
but then also has to be able to learn
learn about his movement
learn how to use his body to communicate
with others
all those kinds of things that dogs know
how to do well humans know how to do
somewhat well i think that's a beautiful
challenge but first you have to allow
the robot to make mistakes
well i think your objective is laudable
but you're going to realize that the
boston
dynamics folks are right the first time
spot poops on your rug
um i hear the same thing about kids and
so on yes i still want to have kids no
you should it's it's a great experience
um so let me
step back into what you said in a couple
of different places one i have always
believed that the missing element in
robotics and artificial intelligence is
a proper
development right it is no accident it
is no mere coincidence
that human beings are the most dominant
species on planet earth and that we have
the longest childhoods of any
creature on earth by far right the
development is the key to the
flexibility
and so the capability of
a human at adulthood is the mirror image
it's the flip side
of our helplessness at birth
um so i'll be very interested to see
what happens in your
robot project if you do not end up
reinventing childhood for robots which
of course is foreshadowed in
2001 quite brilliantly
you